joining me now is Mike hakabe former
governor of Arkansas and Chris Bedford
executive editor of the Common Sense
Society Governor none of that deters
people from Crossing illegally so what
is the
point well the point is Joe Biden wants
an open border he thinks he's importing
Democrat voters for the future but
here's the outrage we got about uh
35,000 veterans who are homeless in
America right now have no place to go uh
they're not getting free rent they're
not getting hotel rooms with meals there
are 650,000 homeless people in the
country we just let 7 million in and
we're providing everything including a
college education for them you know it
makes me kind of think that this year
for vacation I'll not go anywhere I'll
go to the southern border I'll walk
across and say I'd like a hotel room
like some Health Care uh give me some
meals I'll just vacation here in the US
and let Uncle Joe pay for it because he
seems to really love this idea of
slipping across the southern border no
questions
asked it sure does uh Chris you know and
and to show the the expectation and
maybe you certainly call it the lack of
gratitude uh here's the New York Times
on December 13th some of these folks
that are getting these meals are saying
uh it's just not good enough for us
here's the here's the quote New York
City is paying tens of thousands of
dollars a month for meals that are
supposed to go to feed migrants but
instead are never eaten and thrown away
according to internal documents so Chris
not only are we paying for meals but
we're wasting meals that they're not
eating because they're not good enough
even though they're free for the people
who came here
illegally yeah and that's a story that's
been going out in New York City for all
year now you there's been some
disgusting and awful pictures that have
come out the way these hotels are
treated the way the staff are treated
people don't even want to go in there to
the places where people are being housed
a lot of the times with the amount of uh
debris left over from alcohol and drugs
and the discarded food that's left to
rot and this is putting a real strap on
cities New York City's in crisis right
now Washington DC just was about to run
out of the emergency funding that the
mayor requested to try and deal with
this Massachusetts this Christmas has
passed another $ 250 million just to try
to keep up with some of the housing at a
time at a time that we're actually
dealing with serious problems with our
own citizens with drug addiction and
with people on the streets right now who
really do need those Services they're
being diverted instead to illegal
immigrants and Governor you know I had a
a family friend of ours worked very hard
over the last I don't know four five six
years to prove she was worthy of
American citizenship to get her green
card it we had to get a congressman
involved it was uous she did she
wondered whether she was going to stay
or have to go all the while here legally
but wondering and yet if you come to the
border illegally the process is pretty
easy here's a piece of paper come back
and 5 Years yet so so it's under undoing
our legal system too why would you try
to do it
legally well and it's an insult to the
people who've worked so hard to come
legally look America is a great country
because of immigration thank God we are
a nation that welcomes people from all
over but we don't welcome them to come
illegally we welcome them to take the
proper steps so that we know who they
are why they've come what they're going
to do when they get here do they have a
criminal record or a communicable
disease and then if they don't hey come
and join us in the American experiment
work hard you'll be successful that's
what this country is about but when you
have open borders and illegal
immigration you defy all those people
who for the existence of this country
have come here looking for a better life
and we want that what we don't want is
what we have now under Joe Biden and I
hope voters will go to the polls and say
none of this again we're not going to
keep doing
this totally right Chris last word
you're ahead you're you are ahead of the
Common Sense Society so let's say the
front runner for Republicans wins and he
runs on deporting people who have made
false Asylum claims is that Common Sense
does it make sense can we reverse some
of
this I think it would be very difficult
but if you take it would take political
courage but it's absolutely worthwhile
to do for the protection United States
and protection of our most vulnerable
citizens even Arch libertarian Milton
Friedman said you can't have open
borders and the kind of generous welfare
system the United States has for those
people in this country who need it you
need to choose one or the other and I
think a republican candidate ought to
have the courage to choose
Americans we shall see yeah certainly
putting Americans first as the governor
pointed out with vets and hardworking
people who footing the bill for all this
nonsense Governor hocky Chris thank you
very much hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else